eu sou stefhany no meu cross fox
eu vou sair mudança me divertir e aí
olha esse é o canal todo mundo consegue
se come tudo bem também é que ela quer
começar um vídeo contando uma coisa pra
vocês iam ser muitas mensagens no
facebook e todos os dias eu recebo
muitos pensarem ser mensagem não é todo
mês não é toda a semana não é toda hora
é todo minuto e às vezes acabam não
consigo ver algumas mensagens o que
responder muita gente mas às vezes eu
passo por cima de alguns mas hoje eu dei
a sorte de clicar nessa mensagem que
cara vou falar pra vocês eu acho que foi
a melhor mensagem que eu já falei na
minha filha é uma menina pedia pra
divulgar uma página e eu fui lá ver
qualquer um é capaz de ouvir acho que
uma das idéias mais bilhão que eu já vi
na minha vida é uma casa de abrigo para
tirar as pessoas que moram na rua e essa
casa tem patrocinadores ea casa eo
patrocinador tiveram a brilhante idéia
de a cada propor dida na página ou
patrocinador do mais um real para casa
exatamente àquela portagem que você deve
imaginar compartilho aqui o facebook vai
dar 5 centavos para cada
compartilhamento dessa foto se inicia
por duplas mas dessa vez que é verdade o
testador realmente se comprometeu a cada
partida na página do ar mais real atrai
mais legal é ver jogos de r$1 você
consegue um milhão então acho que chegou
a hora de você usar essa tão maravilhosa
curtindo que você tanto na esfera nas
redes sociais assegurou ainda não sei o
que comeu laico e também por lá e deixar
mais vizinhos o pai falar esse seu lado
não vai pra sua popularidade não vai
para a popularidade da página vai
popularidade pourri se lá que vai ajudar
contribuir um real para as pessoas que
moravam na rua para um segundo tiro na
cabeça
o líquida mais desse primeiro que está
com a descrição do vídeo você clica lá
você vai dar um curtir e você vai
comentar no mural da marginal nas
postagens ter sido eu consigo ir com um
muito obrigado muito obrigado também
quero pedir logo se você curtiu os
vídeos se você vem aqui frequentemente
os meus vídeos se você gosta dos meus
vídeos eu me divirto clique aqui não
gostei que você me ajuda muito
ontem foi sexta feira 13 e quando é
esses dias decidi da tdt hoital agora
começa a treinar mais as superstições
eu não sei se todo mundo mas eu lembro
da supersan time eu tinha medo que
muitos super salvador pequeno quando era
pequena chave assistir televisão até
tarde da noite e da noite basta filme de
que de terror que aprendi também que
passava sempre ver né mas eu nem eu nem
assistir
imagina quando eu assisti o filme terror
e geralmente o filho tentava assim umas
12 6 uma hora da manhã e aí quando
acabar o filme de terror
quem está decidido só faz é louca sabe
que eu não sei que a doença está debaixo
do sol faz para não descer para pegar no
pé pior é quando esse dia chegar na
porta do quarto da porta do quarto negro
não culpa que eu na verdade por box
eu tinha muito medo porque a meia noite
é o pessoal tenha a superstição de que
de toda a minha noite tudo que é coisa
ruim começa a pairar pela cidade e até
na questão legal que depois da meia
noite o capítulo vai ao banheiro outro
capítulo à porta da geladeira do capeta
fica embaixo da cama por isso eu comprei
cama box é o capeta do cabelo baixo
agora tenho um debate a reflexão assim
eu era uma criança deixar um monstro
horrível porque falta quisesse pegar a
minha perna puxará eu te pergunto o que
diabo que o capitão é fazer debaixo da
cama de uso pessoal que minha mãe falava
muito é pequeno é que não podia misturar
manga com leite e tomassem humana por e
morria engraçado que ele pergunta se a
mãe eu tomei de manhã eu posso comer
manga e agora ela fala não é porque não
pode por que falar mal mas foi mal
porque foi mais pronto que avançou eu
sou sua mãe nossa boca língua chinesa na
cara só que eu acho engraçado é que que
não faz mal nenhum você cresce você toma
o leite humano e é normal por isso eu
acho que superstição é coisa de mãe
há muita teoria da geladeira assim eu
tenho do seu cabo esse leite todinho meu
deus o meu deus essa manga aqui para te
deixar foi a vitamina agora já assumiu
feminino como tu já sei vou inventar uma
coisa maior do meio ambiente após
comemora não porque que não vai morrer
outro aspecto que me falaram muito que
era pequeno eu tinha muito medo era do
chinelo mercado com alguém viu tinha
embarcado menino céu
a embarcação na hora só porque por que
reza a lenda que se o sean do filho que
vem bocado a mãe morre
meu amigo se chegasse na casa de um
amigo diversas telas bocado falava meu
filho o meu deus numa manhã é um cara
pelo amor de deus não quer chegar embora
cada dia que ele é é chamativo ucraniano
na hora ela mordeu desemboca aquele
negócio a cada minuto que aquilo ali tem
por cadu é é uma espinha dela que está
quebrando caso tenta como pode um
engraçado é que o porto não tem nada a
ver morte um chinelo e diz qual foi a
última vez que você chega no velório de
uma mãe e falou assim me xinga a ver
nuno tenho tem nexo cara que só reforça
minha teoria de que superstição é coisa
que mãe vento está muito abalada na casa
de boa não há de novo parece me um só
deles tinha embarcado cara pelo amor de
deus tive a idéia é isso meu filho que
foi mãe que foi coisa menos coisa muito
que a água doce
tenho certeza que tinha embarcado formal
dizia minha voz na china bancada uma mãe
na hora para outra resolver o problema
nada de chinhama embarcar na casa que
amanhã eu vivi para as empresas pensam
que me diziam quando era pequeno é que
você não podia dizer que o recém nascido
era bonito não se você falar que o
recém-nascido é bonito ea noiva e vai
crescer fez a ele perde eu vou chamar
recém nascido de bonito pra que o meu
agente me perdoe mas um menino
recém-nascido a coisa mais horrível que
existe nessa terra e gente a criança
quando nasceu nas contagens de culto
verdiano fazendo caretas gentil remata
necessidade de dizer com a criança dessa
é bonita quando cresce um ano um ano e
meio dois anos a ética política nunca
imaginei ver a peça o rio daqui eu acho
que quando eu era recém nascido elogiado
tanto eu quero que você acha que os
comentários alguns super só você acha
muito esquisita o que você tem medo
alguma coisa assim se você gostou do
vídeo você já sabe né você deixa ele
coxim legal que é a primeira vez que
você está vendo aqui clique em inscrever
se tudo estiver de novo você vai saber
vídeo novo toda sábado toda quarta-feira
beleza segue aqui no twitter segue no
facebook segue estarã e é isso aí falou
anos essa camisa é legal aqui você
encontra no site da cangaço caso você
queira comprar um palavrão
enquanto isso você olha para a minha
fase legal vou cantar uma música pra
vocês é seu vizinho que quer que me com
ele no seu vizinho que quer comer gruen
os serviços em cédula pelican na estrada
você não tá linda né
se não gosta rosa lapada na rachada você
pede que eu te dou a panachaiki gostoso
no paraná rashan encantando alegre
sertanejo alekna que léa
é que alec leque leque lec na dodge ram
me camaro amor em dobro